one of the things that i have noticed
living in los angeles is that
l.a los angeles rams are in the super
bowl yeah you wouldn't know it to drive
around l.a
am i right
you drive around la and you don't see
any signage i don't see anyone wearing a
ram's hat because that's just the way la
is um i'm serious i've been driving
around a lot i saw one city bus that
went it just had one little electric
signs and it said uh stops frequently
and then the next message that came up
was go rams
that was question mark yeah it was a
question mark
go rams i mean they weren't even sure
i didn't grow up in a town like this i
grew up in boston massachusetts and in
boston massachusetts you have to wear
your red sox cap when the red sox are
playing you have to wear your patriots
cap when the patriots are playing you
have to wear a bruins jersey when the
bruins are playing you have to wear a
celtics jersey when the celtics are
playing and people take it really
seriously true story my father went out
to get groceries a couple of years ago
when the patriots were in the super bowl
and he forgot to put on his patriots cap
yeah two years in prison
he spent two years in prison for that
they pulled him over he didn't have his
hat two years yeah uh unbelievable
that's the intensity of what is
happening in
that's crazy it's crazy no i i like this
where people are like yeah it's cool
we're in the super bowl nice job guys oh
i bet you right now and i think this
crowd agrees with me if i went around to
la and randomly asked people are you
excited about the rams yeah two-thirds
of them would spray mace in my face
and they would say i was i was attacked
by a woman in a corduroy jacket
a tall orange-haired woman they wouldn't
know what was going on i almost forgot
the rams came back i remember they were
here and then somebody said oh the rams
are in the super bowl i was like oh
you know what's really sad when you have
a football team that leaves and no one
notices
it's like someone who leaves a party and
then wanders back later on and go i bet
did you go
oh i feel terrible i mean but that's
what happened the rams left now they're
back but uh you know are you excited
about it is anyone in your family
excited about it people in my family are
i'm not you know i
i'm not gonna lie i don't know why we're
in the super bowl thing you're i don't
think of conan o'brien when i think of
the super bowl and i certainly think
well first of all well first of all you
don't know anything about football and
this is a true story absolutely true
story
sona walked in to do the podcast today
okay this is about 45 minutes ago and
this is absolutely true okay my dad
didn't do two years in prison for not
working hard you got me there no
but
sona walked in 45 minutes ago and
learned for the first time that tom
brady had retired from football that is
actually very true you didn't know i had
heard there were like he was they were
like oh he might retire and i was like
okay and then i just found out that he
had announced you found out you found
out obama was president during his
second term that was you were always and
crazily misinformed he had two terms
yeah he had two terms wow yeah okay a
little less of the edible
a little more of the read the newspaper
um
anyway read a newspaper well online i
know it's not cool to have paper
uh but anywho you know this is to
contrast it cincinnati yeah okay the
bengals cincinnati is giving kids
the day off from school
the day after the super bowl on monday
everyone in cincinnati has the day off
this has been declared like everyone no
school regardless if they win or lose
what yeah
and in l.a
you could
no no one even knows in cincinnati
they're shutting everything down they're
going to empty the hospitals
they're going to have bulldozers destroy
the library so no one can use them on
monday everything's going to be
completely shut down they're not going
to put fluoride in the water
everything's being shut down okay on
that day and it's just going to be just
lawlessness craziness mad max beyond
thunderdome it's going to be nuts all
right that's how seriously they're
taking it and then of course here we are
in la